um so welcome to the wps seminar
everyone um before we introduce our
invited speaker let's go over some rules
and logistics as usual
first of all please mute yourself during
the talk unless you have questions if
you have questions you are welcome to
admit and ask otherwise please use chat
room to post your questions so that we
can address them in q a session at the
end second today's ddps seminar is open
to external audiences therefore no
classified discussion is allowed so
please watch out
finally the talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our youtube channel
that's about it now let me introduce our
speaker today
it is an honor to host dr
talin uh who is a postdoctoral scholar
in the department of computer science at
stanford university
working with the professor joe
laskovac
his research interests include
representation learning and machine
learning for scientific simulation and
inverse design using tools of graph
neural networks and information theory
he obtained his phd
in mit physics where his thesis focused
on application of machine learning to
physics and introducing physics
insights techniques into machine
learning
today thailand will give a talk about
to
accelerate large-scale physical
simulations in fluid and plasma physics
i'm sure he will give a wonderful talk
so please enjoy it
now without further ado let me pass the
button to thailand by asking a random
question
that is it's not that random
the question is
what is your favorite things to do
during the weekend
after answering this question you can go
on with your talk pilots
um
okay so very nice to meet you all so the
question uh i think
the thing i like to do most if you can
right now is to watch sci-fi movies
watch movie okay
what movie uh sci-fi movie oh sci-fi
movie yeah yeah yeah any favorite movie
you can name
uh like the
expense or maybe some other
tv that includes sci-fi okay well i i
don't
watch sci-fi movie usually so i don't
know them all right it's 50 years
okay so yeah very nice to meet you all
today my topic is about learning to
accelerate large-scale physical
simulations in fluid and plasma physics
so firstly i would like to give a
further overview of the
different kinds of simulations we might
encounter in applications
uh the first kind is that we uh
discretize the whole state into a fixed
grid or a match and we want to um like
simulate the evolution on this match
second we have the particle-based
simulation in which uh the individual
elements are the particles that can move
around
this includes light water or galaxy
simulation
the third kind is the platforming cell
simulation in which we
the elements include both the grid and
the particles
uh this is mainly uh uh applied in the
plasma physics where we have the foster
field and the ion electrons as particles
so
uh simulation is very important in both
science and engineering
and
i think there are at least two calculus
tips that are
omnipresence in all of these simulations
one is that they are a very
very large scale in size it is typically
at a problem of the high performance
improvement
and nevertheless even with this much
computation
it may still take a long time
and to do some reasonable simulation
for some small systems
for example for a 3d laser plasma
integration system
in order to
make it to have some reasonable uh like
system dissemination you might need
billions of cells
and to simulate over a long time step
and even then
it may still um like
uh simulate only a fraction of the
usual
assistance that we bought for simulation
the second characteristic is the
following uh the dynamics typically is
multi-scale
and have a large standard range
for example uh
the there are some fine scale
dynamics
there are there are some very highly
energetic
parts of the system that we need to
resolve to a fine scale but there are
also some other parts of the system they
are less dynamic and we can use a closer
grid
and it is typically
not not possible to simulate them using
a single scale
for example for a plasma system
where there's a laser that's shooting
from the left you can see that the
middle has a very dynamic
evolution and
the maybe there are only a small
percentage of particles
but it can for example constitute a
large fraction of the energy
this opens the door for optimization
that we can maybe use the different uh
scale or different uh
models to simulate different aspects of
the system
sorry
so typically to address this uh
simulation uh in the large scale systems
uh we have the classical servers
which are based on first principles and
interpretable
and they are accurate and have some good
error guarantees
but their challenge is that they
typically require a large engineering
effort to develop and is typically slow
because of due to the limitation in the
time interval or the implicit method
required to ensure the numerical
stability
recently there are a search of the
different target models
which offers some benefits
uh
the pros are the following because the
model can
directly learn the
model from the data it requires less
engineering effort
and also we can use a larger time
interval and maybe use the explicit
forward evolution which can be faster in
inference time
and it has the potential to address the
multiscale challenge where we can use
different
models to learn different aspects of the
system
but on the other hand there are also
some challenges of the data gm models
which
there are some challenge in the long
term rollout and to ensure that we can
still maintain the numerical stability
that we roll out the system for a long
time
and also currently it lacks some
theoretical guarantees for
the generic deep learning model
so i think
uh
these two parts these two solutions for
the simulation are not one replacing the
other but i think the best way is to
combine the best of both worlds where
either we can use the machine learning
to correct parts of the classical server
or we can
incorporate
some inductive bias into the deep
learning model to make it more accurate
and long-term stable
so here i will first
provide a general definition of the
dynamical system and the problem we want
to solve
so
a dynamical system can be thought of as
there are some state of the system that
is evolving which is u of t
and
this state can be defined on a grid a
mesh or as a collection of particles or
it can be even as a function
and then
the p here is the static parameters of
the system for example it can be some
diffusion coefficient or it can be the
mass of the particle etc
which does not change with time
but influence the system at each time
step
and we have the boundary of the system
satisfying some boundary condition
we also may have some controls external
can show f of t
that we exert on the system
and then we have a ground shoot a model
f of star
that evoke the state
it can be a ground truth over or it can
be some measurement of the actual
physical process
and the problem we want to address is
the following
given the tuples of the
state by each time step as well as the
static and control parameters
and also the target at the next time
step
we want to learn a model
that can
match very well with this prediction
and the goal is not only to predict one
handstand very well but also in the
influence time when we evolve the system
using this model also regressively we
can still uh
obtain a reasonable evolution
and the f
here
in general can be a convolutional
network it can be a graph neural network
or it can be a neural operator that
evolves the function itself
so besides this we can also have the
inverse problem of
like suppose that we have already
learned the model
and uh
now we also have some objective we want
to optimize for example we want to
[Music]
design the boundary of the system such
that he optimize some
objective line minimize the drag or
maximize some certain
objectives
and then the problem is then to optimize
some static parameter or maybe the
boundary or maybe the control parameter
such that it optimizes our predefined
objectives
so in this talk i will
try to address
uh the following
two to three questions
so first question is how to learn a
model f system that can faithfully
evolve the system long time
and the second question is
if the state u of t has a multi-scale
dynamics
how do we properly model it
and if we have time we can also touch
upon
some of recent work of our work that
perform the inverse optimization
of the length model
and
uh note that our solution is just
some solution
over one
over many possible solutions and he's
still in the active development
so for the first question
are we
mainly focusing on a subsurface
simulation in which we want to model the
rollout the stimulation of the
oil and water flowing underground
for the second question the multi-scale
challenge we mainly focus in on a plasma
laser system
that we want to model is small physical
dynamics
for the third question
we are mainly investigating it on a
navier source equation
fluid
so for the first for the first part
sub-surface relation
uh this is a the collaboration with a
run company
so
basically the problem is the following
uh we want to develop a model that can
predict the flow the flow of fluids for
example the water or oil or the gas
through the porous media underground
and this is essential for the management
of the oil and gas and groundwater
resources
and is also pivotal in industrial
applications for example in oil industry
and having a good model can ensure a
fast and accurate
like evolution that are needed for the
downstream decision making for example
how to or where to drill a new wheel
and it is also important
to ensure that the production is
economically efficient and may be able
to reduce the carbon emission
so as a background here i will introduce
the simplified pde for the system
basically the whole simulation tries to
model how the pressure as well as the
water and oil saturation
like e wolf on the ground where
basically uh the s i is the saturation
of either water or the oil which the
situation means that what is the
fraction of the
water or oil that occupies the porous
media of the rock
which goes from 0 to 100 percent
and then the pressure is the p here
basically the change of the saturation
of water or oil depends on two times the
one turn is the source or sink where the
sorcerer's sink are the wells that
either inject water or maybe produce the
water or oil
at the shell location
and then there's another turn which is
the divergence of the flux
basically the change of this saturation
depends on the source of sink and also
the total amount of the fluid flowing
into the current cell
where the flux here is proportional to
the gradient of the pressure basically
it will flow from the high pressure
plate to a low pressure place where the
coefficient here depends on
what we call a relative permeability
and this mental probability krg
also is a nonlinear function of the
saturation itself
so basically this will make the whole
pde non-linear and very intelligent to
assimilate
so classical servers typically use an
implicit method to evolve the system
where each cell
will constitute one equation
where even like if we have millions of
equations like within cells then we have
a minus of millions of equations
and then it will be very uh time
consuming to solve
and
uh so for the current physics based and
they have given models you still need to
address the long-term evolution
multi-scale dynamics challenge
where they might have thermodynamics
means that we need to model both the
potential dynamics which is
happening on a much global scale and
also this model how the water and oil
flow
between the neighboring cells which is
much much more local
and also we need to scale to millions of
nodes
so
to address this question
uh like typical physics-based models
project the whole system into some
reduced basis although it can simplify
the system
it will it is inefficient
insufficient to model this nonlinear
multiscale behavior
for the contribution models
typically use the data to render
evolution and it has shown the promising
results but up to now it has been
limited to apply to the 2d problem
with up to 10k cells
and the work that is most similar to
ours is the graph neural simulator that
is developed by deep mind
where they apply it for the particle
based simulation and apply it up to 20k
particles
but that pro by the model is not
designed for this system which is
based on a match and also it is much
less
size
so in this work we basically introduce a
hybrid graph network simulator
which consists of a
graph network to model the dynamics of
the water and oil
and also a 3d unit which models the more
global dynamics of the pressure
and we also develop training techniques
to improve the long-term accuracy
and also performance performing some
strong baselines
and we apply up to 1.5 million cells and
achieve total 184 speed up
so
recall in our previous diagram
and in this system our input
contains the dynamic variables which are
pressure and the saturation
and then the static parameter includes
the log properties such as the
permeability velocity and so on which
model how the rook is able to transduce
fluid
and we also have the control variable
that is uh how much of the
fluid is injected to the
cl at each time step
and then we also have some competitive
features
which we compute for the network to be
able to
uh easier to model
and the output is the dynamic variable
at the next time step
so
uh basically yeah here our model has two
parts the gnn and the 3d unit
basically we discretize the whole uh 3d
grid into this
3d cell structure
where for the gn we model each cell as a
node where it has the edge
that connecting it towards these six
neighbors
and then
our gn uses this encoder processor
decoder
architecture where the encoder embeds
the input into the latent graph of the
node and the edges
and the processor includes a stack of
m layers
at each layer it performs the typical
gin operations where it first
based on the
every pair of notes
and the edge feature to compute
a message between this pair of notes
and then he aggregates the message
on each note
and then based on the aggregate message
he will usually to update the note
feature at the next time steps
and after a few layers of this
uh the last layers node feature will be
used as the prediction for the next 10
steps
so
having this model
we still have the challenge of the
long-term rollout
basically what we find is that even if
we
train the model with one step loss to a
very low loss
it is still uh
very hard to roll out into a long time
step even basically the error will
diverge
and the cause of this is that
during rollout we use the model's
prediction as the input for the next 10
step and the error
by the model can accumulate after we
look out for longer time steps
and to address this uh test
problem
our pathworks has introduced several
approaches
one is to add noise into the training
input and this noise can simulate some
of the roll-out area during the
influence and can make the model more
robust
and then another work by maxwelling they
introduce the nice
adversarial knights which are generated
by the motor floor itself
so in this work
we find that when we train the model
with the autoregressive layout it
actually performs much better
and specifically which means the
following
typically when you train the model they
just use you just use the model to
predict one time step in the future and
then you compare it with the ground
truth so this is the one step box
but instead we also
use the model to go out a few more 10
steps and for each time steps in the
future we also compare the graph with
the ground shots and control the dots
and our goal is to minimize the
summation of other losses
and in this way the model is trained to
model the long-term dynamics pattern
and you have some weights for each time
step
focusing more on the one step loss but
also have some weight for the
longer time steps
uh yeah so in this way we find that uh
it
allows the model to go out much longer
uh apart from this we also have the
challenge of the large science because
if you have millions of cells per times
that
we cannot fit the whole thing into a
single gpu
therefore we introduce the sector-based
training in which uh basically we have
partitioned the whole data upgrade into
many sectors and in each sector
uh we also have the overlap in the
sector because we don't want to compute
the loss
at the boundary of the center because
they are less accurate
so then
uh became just the sector as the turning
data instead of the
full grid
so here are some results of the
of our method we basically compare our
method with
some strong baselines of the 3d unit
and a convolutional neural network
we roll out the model for 10 steps or 20
steps into the future and compare the
prediction of the pressure water and oil
and as you can see our model outperforms
the other models by a large match margin
we also perform the evolution study in
which
one amplitude is that we only use either
the 3d unit or the gn to model the full
system instead of modern then
respectively and we find and we find
that
the error with the full model is much
better than using
a single model to model them both
because
the 3d unit is more suitable to model a
more global dynamics and the gnn here is
more suitable to model local dynamics
we also find that if we train with one
step loss the performance is much worse
than trained with a multi-step loss
this uh
lie
confirms that the multi-step loss can
really help the long-term rollout
and here we see that our model uh
have a lag much less cells
that have some area above some threshold
so here is some robot where we see that
we have an injector that inject water
into some some place
and then we have a producer that produce
the oil water
and then as the time goes by
we see that the water
is flowing from the injector to the
producer in the middle and we see that
our model matches very well with the
ground tubes
and here it is the oil
visualization in which we see that the
oil
is depleted
due to the producer in the middle
and it matches also very well with the
ground tubes
so for the speed uh our method
our model uses
20 seconds to roll out 20 steps
with a gpu in comparison a standard
server with multiple
nodes takes around 46 seconds to 370
seconds
to do the same
simulation which
is a total of 18 volt reduction in the
time
and right now we are scaling our model
to 50 million cells and we are also able
to uh model the well of our production
uh with very small lots
yeah so basically in this first part uh
we are going to introduce this hybrid
model to model this subsurface
simulation and we introduce this
multi-step locks to improve the
long-term loadout
okay so this is the first part
of the sub-surface simulation
for the second part we are going to
introduce our work on the laser plasma
interaction
uh basically in here
this is the work we collaborated with
slack and ucla
so
firstly what is a plasma
so a plasma
consisting of ions and three electrons
and on light of typical materials that
where the electrons are bound to the
ions in the plasma the electrons can
freely move around
and the electrons and ions are
interrupted by the en field
examples of these are the fire the sun
the lightning etc
so the nasoplasma interaction is a very
important application
where we have some laser uh high energy
laser that shoot from the left and there
are some material here
that are in a sudden vaporize into a
plasma
and then after the interaction some of
the ions or electrons will go to the
backward and it will heat some target on
the back background here
which can be used for
material or medicine or fusion
so
typically
to model this process
a particle in cell method is used
which
use both the cell and the particles to
model the whole dynamics
so
so the simulation of the plasma is very
difficult because of the long-term
interaction between the ions and
electrons
and suppose that we have n ions and
within the time frame each ion can
actually
influence
all the other electrons or ions so
there is a unsquare uh for example
unsquare time complexity of the system
if we model a pair of bias interactions
between each particle
and if the n is median then the n square
will be trillions which is uh impossible
to simulate
uh typically the physics uh solution is
the following
uh instead of modeling the pair by
interaction between ions and electrons
we use the field en field as a medium
to transduce the interaction
basically we model both the ions
electrons and the fields and they
interact
locally
and specifically the whole simulation of
the pic particle in cell consists of
this
four step process
uh basically
the ions and electrons can move freely
and we model the electromagnetic field
on the vertices of the grid
and
in the first sub step
we
interpolate the electromagnetic field
from the grid vertices to the particle
to obtain the field at the vertical
location
and then
based on the field
uh we use the range equation to
advance the momentum and the position of
the field
of the particle
and then the next
next step
uh
when the particle moves it will also
induce some current and the current we
can deposit them onto the field vertices
and finally based on the field nearby
and also the current deposited we can
also update the field at each time step
so basically we iterate this fourth
subset process
to evolve
both the ion electron and also the field
so is this clear
okay so
typically
this laser plasma interaction
involves the multi-scale dynamics
by microscope i mean the following
suppose the laser shoots from the left
and this bug is the plasma
and we can see that
only a small fraction of the
uh
region
is
excited and the majority of the whole
region is like very static
in the position and
momentum phase space we can also see
that
a majority of the particles uh stays
in the classy thermal background where
their distribution of the momentum
obeys a gaussian distribution and a
small fraction of the particles they are
injected by the laser to a high energy
and they constitute a majority of the
energy but they have very small flexion
so we can see that here there is a scale
separation in the momentum of the
particles
and the typical part in particle in cell
server needs to resolve the smallest
skin depth here
and to model the highly dynamic
particles as well as all these thermal
particles at the same time
which is very very inefficient because
this part of the particle that is
thermal can be modeled with a much
closer scale
and
such
similar
uh types of line multiple dynamics can
be also find in many other applications
where a small fraction of the system is
highly dynamic and need to resolve to a
very fine scale and the majority of the
system is much less dynamic
this can be found in
nuclear fusion and also in galaxy
information
and recall that
the benefits the cons and challenges of
the classical servers and the detachable
models
so to address this multiscale challenge
why not combine the best of both worlds
where we use the accurate uh solvents to
model the
very dynamic particle and use the
consumer model to learn the more closer
line
particles
so
based on this uh
idea we basically introduced this fluid
and particle hybridization in which we
use the fluid
to represent the majority of the
thermoparticles
and basically we model them using
the moments of the particles in each
cell
because in each cell we may have
hundreds of particles tomorrow then we
may
need to provide their state at
for each particle
but if we model them as a fluid where we
can only use a mean or standard
deviation
for
to represent all these particles in a
single cell then we can reduce it to a
few numbers
and then we can use the
neural network to learn the evolution of
these moments
and for the other particles that are
highly energetic we can still use the
classical solvent to evolve them
so
by doing this uh separation we also have
another thing that to do which is
injection basically if test step there
are also some particles that are
injected from the fluid state to the
particle state and we also learn a
neural network to model this injection
from the fluid state to the particle
state
specifically
our model is the following
so
these are two time step n and plus one
and then
we use the
particle in cell server to model and
push those highly energetic particles
from time step n to n plus one
and then we use a cnn
to model the
evolution of the moments at each cell
at this time step here
and also we use another neural network
which is the particle injection network
to model the injection
of the
particle from the fluid state basically
this model predicts a distribution like
the mean and standard deviation of the
distribution and then sample from it the
new particles
so here are some results
and
so this is the result for the fluid
advanced network prediction
and
uh
the x-axis is the position and then the
y-axis is a time step
from 500 to 1000
and here we
uh visualize the
change of the electron density and the
ion density
uh ash time step and it is a single step
prediction which means that in each time
step we feed the ground truth and use
and ask the model to predict one time
step in the future
as you can see
the our prediction matches quite well
with the ground tunes
both for the electron and the ion
and it also captures this periodic
injection
of the
electrons and ions
by the laser
this is the fluid advanced networks and
then we also have the particle injection
network where it predicts and injects
the particle at each time step
and we can also see that the network
prediction matches quite well with the
ground tools
so after having trained these models
the hard part
is to combine this together to achieve a
long-term low out
and this lonesome road uh yeah
uh is extremely challenging especially
for this plasma system because this
system is highly
chaotic
so here are some results of its
preliminary loans uh we still need to
improve our model right now where we use
our model
uh
we provide the ground tools and some
kind step and we use our model
including the fluid advance and the
particle injection to model there
to advance the full state
for 20 steps
and
we can see that right now it
uh
does not do so well likely because that
our model right now is trained yeah with
one step
uh but later when we change this
multi-step maybe it can do better
and then here it is the prediction of
the current at 10 step 1 and time step
where the blue curve is the ground truth
and the orange curve is the prediction
and we see that right now it
matches quite well
so in this part we have introduced
this hybrid fluid and particle
orientation to
address the multi-scale challenge of the
momentum separation of the scale
and we use the
fluid representation to represent the
less dynamic thermal particles and we
also use the
classical silver to evolve the more
energetic uh particles and this way we
can combine the best of both worlds
and the three part because we use much
less
number of
values we can achieve speed up
so
now we have
like
five to ten minutes i will quickly uh go
through the third part which is the
inverse optimization
and basically
uh before the two parts is the
we try to learn a model that can involve
the system long term
but after we have learned the model
uh we are endowed with the probability
of doing the inverse operation of octets
in the boundary or the
some other aspects of the system
so basically we can use the our length
model
and then
use the objective to do bad propagation
with respect to the
boundary or the parameter of the system
so then we can uh optimize
our system to optimize this objective
so this is actually the method proposed
by a deepmind paper this year which
firstly they learned the physical
simulation
from time step 1 to maybe 100 and then
to optimize the boundary they take the
full gradient backward
and then
to
optimize the boundary
uh in their paper they show that it is
able to learn a good authentication
but
the cons is that uh when the dimension
is very large like millions of cells per
time step this method is not scalable
because we need to take the full
gradient backward
and then each time we update the
parameter we need to do the forward and
backward again
with these millions of time steps
uh cells over 100 timestamps
so in a network we
want to split this up and basically we
introduce this latent evolution of ptes
in which instead of uh learning the
evolution in the input space where we
want to create a state and input space
we map our input into a latent space
and
we
we learn a model that can evolve the
state in the design space and only when
it needed we decode it back into the
input space
so if the input space has millions of
cells our latin space can
be maybe 100 times a smaller number of
dimensions
in this way we can achieve speed up both
in the forward and in the backward
organization
so basically our archer in this work is
that we have
an encoder that encodes the dynamics
into sound latent
representation v which is a single
vector
and then we also encode some static
parameter p into
some static latent state v of p
both of which
v and del p are some latent vectors
and then we also learn a model g that
involves this latent vector
and
the h here is the decoder
so
in the inverse of organization what we
want to do is maybe that we want to
optimize the boundary of the system
for example
in the airplane design we may want to
design the boundary so that it minimizes
the drag
and in the fluid control we may want to
uh optimize the fluid boundary so that
life in here the smoke can pass through
the
exit with some predefined
fraction
and
to do this
we can simply take
the
gradient backward instead from the input
space we take the gradient backward in
the latent space
uh and because of the latent space has
much less dimension
we can
achieve speed up by
having this much less dimension dynamics
so here we compare with uh our model
like an evolution
with
an ablation where we don't do the latent
evolution and we evolved the whole state
in
inquiry space
we also compare with a application in
which
we
use the
uh we also compare with the state arc of
the fourier neural operator
model
and as you can see here
our model with latent evolution use much
less time than the one in the
using the input space evolution
and also
basically for the objective we want to
optimize which is the fraction of the
smoke that pass through some certain
cell
we can also achieve much less error
so
okay so here it is the runtime
uh where our model here
is able to
use much less time
than the other comparison
we also show that with latent evolution
not only can we
model the inverse operation
is much quicker and more accurate we are
also able to speed up the forward
evolution
uh
with much speed up with up to 15 times
in speed and with four to a hundred
thousand times compression of the space
while achieving a similar accuracy
for example in the 1d system of the
burgers equation
our model outperforms the statistics and
pde learning models
sometimes and able to achieve
up to line of line 15 times
compression and then 10 times speed up
in a 2d level of stealth equation our
motor is 8 is able to
model the evolution of the turbulent
flow very well and also the performance
is similar to the state-of-the-art model
and in a 3d navier-source equation
our model is also able to capture
in a reasonable way the turbulent
dynamics
where we have a flow through the
cylinder
okay so as a summary
in this talk we aim to address the three
questions
of the large-scale simulation
so to answer the first question of how
can we learn a model
that can faithfully evolve long-term
we introduce this a multi-scale a
multi-step rollout during training which
we demonstrate that it can uh better
evolve the mod system uh longer term
for the question of how can we model the
multi-step scale dynamics where one part
of the system
consists of very small fraction but can
constitute a large fraction of energy
we use a hybrid fluid and particle
repetition to evolve it where we use the
solver to represent and evolve the
highly energetic particles and we use
the neural network to model the less
energetic
parts where we model the evolution of
the moment
and to speed up the inverse operation
instead of um
doing it in the input space we learn a
later immersion model in which we can
optimize the boundary in a latent space
and we also showed that we can achieve
speed speed up while maintaining a good
accuracy
okay this is the talk and thank you and
please ask questions
and
yeah thank you thank you so much for the
wonderful talk thailand um i enjoyed it
a lot uh we do have a uh questions
uh in the chat room let me read it to
you from the beginning
the first question from the pat
he asked
don't data driven approaches still
require the same engineering efforts
to create a classical model in order to
generate data
right there
i think so that was in response to one
of the early to the early slides
thailand where you you were passing the
two approaches
and you were saying that the
that the classical approach required a
big engineering effort and but if you if
you're going to use them to generate
data you still need to do that
engineering effort do you not
uh
yeah the thing is the following so
uh the data from the deep learning mode
uh technology model it can come from
either the engineering effort of the
server it can also come from physical
measurement where we don't need to
develop the server but just mention it
from the
from physical measurement
this is true in
frankfort in many of the
systems
in which we might even not have a good
classical server
and and you get enough data that way
uh yes it can yes
another part is the following so
uh one function of the data trigger
model is not to
replace the server it is a
and store speed under server
basically typically we already have a
server that requires much engineering
effort but they are quite quite slow
and to augment that what we do is the
following we can use the server to
generate the data and then
the customer model can learn the
evolution
um
from the existing server
but it can evolve much quicker and then
based on this technical model it can do
some exploration of the whole landscape
and then
when it finds a good candidate you can
go back to the server to
do a more accurate so okay thank you
well i i guess that was what
pat was pointing out i mean if you are
using the the data from the the physics
over which is expensive that
that does require the engineering effort
uh in some sense
all right so that the next question is
from me
uh using those data
like for example
one of the slides said
20k particle
the neural network
was able to train
how long does it take to train right
yeah
so
so in this system where it has
one million ceos and then
it has
around one thousand time steps
it takes one gpu around two days to
change
okay
yeah
and by this much more gpu we can speed
up
the training time with more resources
yeah i guess
all right so next question is by um
chatap
he asked
for the self-service simulation and
sector-based training and
inference
do you mean at any given time only a
sector of the data is used to train
at a time
for example for a single large mesh with
one thousand by one thousand points only
hundred by hundred sector of that is
used ahead of time
yes exactly
uh
basically
because of the evolution
the pde is local this means that
the equation that can be applied to the
whole thing can be applied to a sector
and we just use a small factor
uh for example
in the whole system this can be 100 x
100 times 100 but then we can use like
14 by uh like 20 by 10 by 20.
and each time we feed the center into
the
model to change
you got to connect them together
in a consistent way by the way
we don't have to basically it's like
the physical process that evolves the
whole thing is actually evolving the
same uh same for the center because the
other following so the gn actually here
is modeling the local evil dynamics
basically it models how the cl is
evolving based on the neighbors of the
cell
and use the same
model to model every node
this means that
um
because it's a local model it can apply
to any any
location in the in the whole system
right yeah what i meant is you know you
know this
the solution from the one sector
will affect the the solution in the
neighbor sector right oh yeah oh that's
one part uh that
needs to be taken care of which is the
following because we have sectors then
the boundary of the sector will receive
less neighbors
and then their prediction will not be
accurate
therefore we do not need we need to not
compute the loss
uh the objective on the boundary of the
sector
otherwise it will bias the laws
uh basically
what we do is that we have some overlap
between sectors
therefore each cell will be at least in
one sector
yeah with the with the overlay they they
see each other
that's the neighbor yeah okay
the next question is by alex do you also
remap in the other direction from
kinetic to fluid i think it's related to
the second topic you yeah that's very
good question so in this work uh we do
not remap back from the particle to the
fluid
because um
this is both authentication and
assumption we make and also because that
once the particle is injected it will be
highly energetic
and very rarely it will go back into the
fluid state with a very
light
like
static and real behavior
all right wonderful okay
the question from pat
some of your mit work use other
induction methods to discover physical
equations do you see deep neural nets as
central to your speedup work or might
they be replaced with other techniques
for inducing models from data
like does this question mean that
we want to infer the symbolic
equation of the
model
how could you clarify this question
sure that would be fine i i don't i
don't care it does it doesn't have to be
an explicit equation i mean that you
could imagine other other approaches to
inducing models from data but certainly
that's the one i had in mind because
both you and i have worked on it
could you use could you use that as a
subroutine rather than the the deep deep
learning stuff
i think so
um
what i think is the following so
uh
i think the reasonable way is the
following we can first use either gnn or
some other neural network
to learn
the model very well
where the loss is some valuable
prediction loss
and once we learn the model variable
we can
pass this
length model
into a symbolic regression or other
pipeline in which we may be able to
delve into this model and extract some
some more insights or equations well you
could do that i was asking whether you
might do it directly
is there any reason
so
for this uh and
[Music]
so what aspect what model do you have in
mind for doing it directly well you're
you're you're you're from the data
simulated or observed you are basically
building
uh pde models uh and you can encode
those in different ways right you can
encode them as a as a
uh
as a
deep neural network or you can encode
them as a set of differential equations
and if you learn the differential
equations directly
i mean i mean there may be something
about this i mean certainly the where
you go to latent space
that's that's a another layer but even
in the latent space you can imagine
learning explicit symbolic equations
and i'm the only reason to ask this
question is because i ask this question
often in these talks i want to tease
apart
what's the general principle versus
what's the specific solution you came up
with here um and if there are other
approaches
that people might prefer should you know
should they consider them
and we don't have to have a final answer
here i just wanted to mostly just wanted
to ask the question
i think
yeah i think this is a very good
question right now i don't have a good
answer i think
as i said another way is to maybe
um
instead of using a generic like graph
network or other network we can
encode the network in a more like pde
like where we have more explicit
currents and then we can
learn for example either coefficient or
the parameter of those terms
this may this more inductive violence
i understand your reservation i mean if
we learned the pdes then we're back to
where if you built the we had the pdes
by hand it'll be just as expensive the
question is whether you could learn
somehow more abstract
more aggregate level pde models
that would run much faster like the
neural net that's the question i don't
have an answer either but it's worth
considering
thank you thank you
all right thank you to both um the next
question is
by
quick one um hi telling it is an
interesting talk my question is how did
you predict a laser plasma
interaction that has a different input
data dimension using a previously
learned model for example you learn
1025 by 1025 grid to learn now we want
to predict a 2048 by 2048 laser plasma
interaction can the model automatically
do that
okay very good question so
um
yeah the answer to the answer is yes
uh because here for both for the fully
advanced network and the
and the particle uh interesting network
we use a cnn a convolutional network to
model it and we know that commercial
network basically is a local model that
try to predict
a sales state based on its
field neighbors in the grid using some
kernel
therefore
uh the confidence here
is
ignorant of
how large your training data is
you just care about the local
dynamics
therefore theoretically if we train with
a smaller size it is able to generalize
to a much larger size
the same goes for the particle part
where
the particle in cell server is by
definition
able to
advance
like either small or large number of
particles because it is still a local
model that try to advance the
particle
and the field in a local way regardless
of the size
hi titan uh
so
uh are you saying you're using the same
kernel size uh for different uh
dimension of input
and you use
uh
are you keeping the uh
structure of the cnn the same or you you
use some way to
uh
for you use some way to tune the
depth of the neural network
for different dynamics
dimensions
uh
different dimensions do you mean the
different features
uh i mean the different uh the grid size
uh
when you're learning the on laser plasma
interaction uh
i think there is a a field field grid
maybe your
input so
uh the dimension when the dimensions are
different are you using the same uh
kernel size yes
but but then uh
then so you are uh you have uh same
same structure of the neural network and
you can still
recover the
uh
uh predict the informations in the
plasma uh well
uh
so
uh actually we haven't done this
experiment yet where we train with a
smaller line size and then generalize to
a larger size
but by definition
of the
like the component
because the component actually is
learning also a local model in which you
just try to model for example our sales
evolution based on the neighboring cells
from up to
like a radius of like
be seven or five
it is actually learning this local model
for the cnn
uh and you obviously during prediction
it uses this kernel to scan the whole
the whole region
so
therefore it can adapt to different
impulses
i mean also need to do this
if not work i think that's huge because
uh
you can have super resolution by only
learn uh
learning on a low uh low resolution uh
data set
so
oh actually uh here
i want to correctly one thing which is
the following
when you say the different
signs do you mean that the resolution is
the same but you make the grid
larger in the position or do you mean
you will have a different resolution
i mean i have a different resolution oh
i see
oh so if you have a different resolution
then a naive convolutional network will
not work because the analyte
convolutional network needs to take into
account
uh have the same resolution and training
and testing
but there may be certain way to fix it
basically during prediction we can also
pass in
the
line of example the position or the
relative position of to the input
and you can train it on the different
solution
and then in this way maybe the network
can generalize over a different
resolution
yeah okay thank you
thank you
okay sounds good the next question from
amit i wonder if you have explored the
pdes
containing a non-local terms
do you see any potential problems in
learning such pdes using the methods you
discussed
okay so
um
we haven't explored that yet
uh what kind of knowledge do you have in
mind
i mean are you there um can you give an
example of the non-local
i mean i i see you are there
you can omit yourself
oh i see the integral my integral over
one yeah integrally i think
yeah um yeah that's a very good question
uh we haven't considered that um
but i think this might be a very
interesting thing to explore and what i
can see the solution is that we
for the location we can also add one
turn
in either the gn or the cn
basically
for the gn in order to model a local
time what we can do is simply is that
we have
a specifically designed gln that have
a much larger
input
radius
and
then based on that
he used it the g n to predict since and
then
sum over all the prediction
to mimic the integral over the full grid
basically we can
use some similar
inductive bias
as the integral to model this non-local
term
and there is also this known local cnm
that use attention to
address different non-local interaction
one problem though is that it will be
very
uh
costly to model because here each cell
can be influenced by all the other cells
potentially
true but i think even in conventional
methods you will still run into the
computational cost issue
so the question is
whether this is doable or not
[Music]
using
using something like this because often
and i'm from quantum simulation
background electronic structure methods
and there are situations where you don't
explicitly know the pde like the
functional form of the pde
and
and there if you at least can learn the
train a model to learn dpd that itself
will be
will be great so that is what was
the motivation behind this question
um let's see
yeah i i think and also i think some of
these
techniques can also be used like
sampling and other ways to make it more
efficient
all right sounds good
so next question is by
the path
again
he said we can ask a similar one about
different time steps i i guess you're
referring to this
upscaling in the spatial grid
yeah
yes so you mean that we train with
one interval but then generalize over a
different interval yes
okay uh
this is also a very good question so
actually in this work let me check
the
mppde paper my message passing pd paper
and
basically what you can
say is the following
in our current work we are not able to
generalize over the different intervals
but
to do that there are at least two ways
uh
from what i thought
one way is that
in during training time we also
put the time step or time t as input or
maybe the time interval as input
and then we train it with multiple
different
intervals so that the network can learn
to generalize over this time interval
this is one natural way
a second way is based on a neural
operator
where
a neuropathy operator
can take as input the time t
and directly output the prediction
and they find that basically if you
train with some even some fixed time
interval
but in an operator you can generalize
over
both the time and the spatial resolution
yeah if you like you can see the paper
which is called fourier
neural operator
that can do both okay thank you you can
ignore my last comment
okay
all right um
[Music]
okay
okay i think the the last question is by
scott a quick question during your
particle injection network steps you use
a cnn to predict a mean and a sigma of
the
distribution doesn't this mean you are
building a
maxwellian-like distribution in pic
often times you get highly nonlinear
distribution functions once you lose
these
um
so yeah basically here
uh
you are right there we are used as cnn
to predict the mean and the derivation
of the distribution
of the injected particles
for example in here we can see that
this part is the thermal which is a
gaussian
in the momentum
but for the injected particles in
momentum we can also see that
although they are highly energetic
and each time
each cell they
may still
uh be us
likely be a single band that have a
different mean
uh and
a standard deviation than the rest we
can think of as there's a main main
caution peak but there are some other
outliers
and most likely it is a um maybe a
single um
gaussian
outside of the main peak
uh this is an
approximation we make using a single
gaussian but
we may also try to use a mixture of
function
to model
it
okay sounds good i i think that was the
last questions and uh the i'm
i mean ask about
he missed the um almost the entire of
your presentation he was asking about uh
if the recording is available and i put
the link in the chat room
if you go to that
webpage
the the
will another tailings
the recorded video will be uploaded
there
not yet but it will be uploaded in the
future near future so you can check that
out
uh in near future
all right um i guess is there any other
questions um
i mean
telling
did a wonderful job answering all those
interesting questions so
and as well as a wonderful talk
let's thank thailand for the wonderful
job today
and it was really good to have you the
pat mentioned that
it was nice to
got thailand to talk in this series i i
totally agree with that
thank you all right thank you thank you
so much and thank you everyone for
joining and uh
i don't know when is the next ddps
seminar but maybe in two weeks there
will be another one all right until then
please
be well and
see you next time